[Music]
let's see what's the next big thing
after large language models the
technology of large language models
which is essentially we could take a
piece of text blank out some amount of
it and then say what will the next word
be try and predict it learn if you get
it wrong and then just repeat over
billions of times you can take picture
and blank out bits of it and try to
predict what's in the past that's
missing you can take a gene sequence and
blank out a piece of it and try and
predict it so this is then a very
successful strategy that can be used for
all sorts of other domains of human
experience and science so we're going to
see a lot of broader use of foundation
models in the soon nearby years even
though large language models have been
incredibly successful they don't really
seem to build the kind of world models
that human beings have where they have a
sense of stuff in a physical world and
particular entities human beings and
their relations that's more abstracted
away from particular sequences of words
and so that suggests we need some kind
of different model of artificial
intelligence but I think it's fair to
say no one really knows the answer of
how to do that successfully and so
that's why we're still doing academic
research AI system asks what are some of
the most promising and exciting real
world applications of NLP that you
foresee emerging in the next few
years ah tons so I think we're going to
see a lot more NLP systems being
deployed very successfully everywhere so
a lot of websites already have a little
AI assistant in the bottom corner I
think we're going to see a new
generation of ones powered by large
language models which really work much
more fluently I think we're going to see
much more use of conversational
assistance so you're thinking about um
how to word an email to your boss or
you're not quite sure what you should
say to your boyfriend it turns out that
you can get advice drafting help
suggestions of what to say um from a
large language model that are actually
useful these days you know I think
there's just a whole world of ways that
we can use these models because our
world is so language based and that
we're all just sort of exploring what
some of the possibilities
are in the future will AI be so smart it
won't need human input I think the
honest answer is no one knows there is a
conceivable world at some point in the
distant future where an AI system can
just learn everything it needs needs
from the world around it and it doesn't
really need us to tell it things but I
think there's also a lot of very heated
hype at the moment some people think
that by 2030 there'll be computers that
are better in human beings at almost all
tasks I think a lot of those views are
fairly irrational exuberance where
people have been getting a little bit
too excited by the very genuine big
advances we made but there are other
ways in which humans knowledge and
ability to operate in the world is
likely to be better than our AI models
for a number of decades to
come will conversational assistance and
chat Bots replace search engines I think
there are different answers for
different kinds of Searchers so one case
is that people just have a particular
question in mind like when is the
primary going to be held in the election
for California to the extent that I've
got a question like that yeah absolutely
conversational agents llms are great for
that sort of purpose that they're faster
and better than something else you could
use you can also use them for all kinds
of other question answering related
purposes sometimes people use search
when they want to take a deep dive
themselves right you know they're buying
a new tent and they'd like to make up
their own mind then there's navigational
queries where they just want to be taken
to the page and that's obviously not
going to be covered by using a large
language
[Music]
model